foreign
[Music]
School Medicine
we work in annual Services we work in
fishing East we use an efficient needs
to study endocytosis and we are mainly
interested in studying how forces
produce and transmitted at the molecular
and cellular level uh uh as a post talk
one of my major projects is to develop a
series of four sensors that can be used
to measure forces at the molecular and
cellular levels so I would like to thank
the organizers for giving me this
opportunity to present our design
principles and some of the results in
measuring Force at endocytosis in
fashionist
my title today is in variable Force
measurement with two one half and zero
cfp green fluorescent protein that shows
how we are able to uh use different
readouts and use different numbers of
fluorescent proteins to achieve the same
result
so I'm going to uh go to the upline of
the slides so in the outline I'm going
to in this talk I'm going to first give
a brief introduction of the importance
of forces for biology why we care about
forces and why do we need to marry them
and also I'm going to introduce the
current state for the art for sensors
which are usually based on threat
measurements to mirror force and the
molecular level and also I'm going to
introduce how we are we are thinking
that we can use a new Motif called quad
coils to make new for sensors
that can be used in other applications
and also be compatible with the FED
readout that's going to going to be the
last part okay
so the first part is the background of
force the importance of forces
so as biologists um sometimes we don't
think that much about forces but force
is actually very important in almost
every aspect of life in the cell biology
and also in developmental biology so
here is a diagram of epithelial cells
you can see that this epithelial cell is
making a contacts with a neighboring
cell and with the basement membrane
so at both of those locations there are
proteins responsible for making
connections either with the receptors on
the other cell or with the ligands on
The extracellular Matrix
so in both of the cases force is
actually very important in stabilizing
the connections and this is important in
both the homeostasis of the cells and
also in the direct developmental process
so in the case of epithelial cells the
um formation of blood vessels is is
heavily influenced by the presence of
Shear flow in the plastering also at the
top of the cell you can see a lot of the
structures there are pumps uh primary
cilia and also iron channels so again in
all those cases force is playing an
important role they are mechanism
channels important for the healthy
health of the cells and for the human
body and also the primary psyllium also
fills forces and response to force
uh in inside the cells again there are a
lot of forces
along the microtubule tracks motor
proteins produce Force to transport
vesicles from different parts of the
young males to different parts of the
cells and between the integrands as you
can see at the bottom of the cells they
form actin stress fibers those also
respond to force so there are results
showing that if you uh
produce a cyclic
stress to the cells then the actin fiber
as well align to the direction of the
forces so the cells will respond to
force and also it's not shown directly
in this diagram but
if you think about host pathogenic
interactions the the
entry of virus particles for example the
SARS Kobe 2 Windows virus particles
enter the cells the membrane has to be
deformed and that deformation of the
membrane will also require the
generation force and again the alert
delivery of the vesicles into the cell
requires Force so again in all those
cases force is playing a very important
role so this is the uh this is showing
you the presence of forcing um many many
aspects of cellular life and how do we
marrow Force we uh in everyday life in
the macroscopic world we met a force
using a very simple device here so shown
on the left you can see the measurement
of the weight of an apple so in this
case the measurement of force is can be
calculated the force can be calculated
by um knowing the deformation of the
spring and if you know the stiffness of
the spring by using the hooke's law you
can calculate force and this is how we
easily calculate force at the
microscopic level
and uh the most the best and most widely
used sensors for Mirror Force at the
molecular level uses the same principle
by using the Hook's law so this is the
threat
um threat approach to Merit force and
this is the force sensor called TS mod
that was developed uh 12 years ago so
you can see here in a panel a
there are two fluorescent proteins
connected by a elastic Linker and the
elasticity or the stiffness of the
elastic Linker can be calibrated in
visual and if those two fluorescent
proteins are close to closer closer to
each other if the force is low then
there will be a high fluorescent
transfer of energy you can marry that by
marrying threat and you be in B you can
see that when the force increases there
will be a increase in the distance
between those two fluorescent proteins
and that will lead to a decrease of red
so similar to the spring in the
measurement of the weight of the Apple
if you insert this construct into a made
out of a protein
you can measure how much force is being
applied on that protein and this has
been a very successful approach I'm
going to show you how many forces are
Merit in this way both inside and
outside the cells you can see in a
that's the connections between cell and
extracellular Matrix and even be between
cell and another cell cell interactions
you can see in those two uh positions
where the force is measured either
inside the proteins or between the
proteins and the extracellular Matrix
I'd like to point your attention to kind
of B and also in the middle of the
diagram you can see a protein called
ventoline
and you can see how a force is Merit uh
between the uh so including is a protein
that connects actin to focal adherence
and the Force Army including has been
measured by the frag sensor to be around
three piconewton using the threat for
sensors so this is a very successful way
of measuring forces
so why do we still want to develop a new
false sensor the reason is that to use
five sensors correctly there are a lot
of things you need to take into
consideration and there are several also
several artists that disadvantage
disadvantages or intrinsic drawbacks of
this threat approach so let's go back
again to this principle of right
measurement uh threat based Force
measurement you have two fluorescent
proteins connected by an elastic Linker
and if you know the elasticity of this
Linker and the separation of those two
fluorescent proteins will give you the
force but this is a diagram
not considering the actual size so on
the right you can see the actual size of
the two fluorescent proteins and the
size of this protein are done choline
where the force is Merit so the winkling
as a protein has a little bit more than
1 000 amino acids and the gfp is 238
amino acids the Linker is 40. so with
two cfp plus a Linker it's almost half
of the size of winkling so to insert
this bulky constructing to the metal
protein into the middle of protein well
well sometimes it leads to the
dysfunction of the proteins
so this is not something that's um
easily tolerated by every protein it's
more tolerated by some of the proteins
at focal adhesions where the size or the
actual size of the uh of our hidden
structures may not matter that much
but there are other proteins actually
the average size of the protein is not
that much bigger than cfp so the
balconies of the flat approach which
requires always at least two fluorescent
proteins is a limitation of this uh
Force measurement another limitation is
to do thread accurately or reliably you
need to do a lot of controls
so this is a very nice review about the
controls that are needed for a reliable
thread environment it's a busy slide but
I will um
walk you through the slide on the upper
left you can see the controls basically
our protein interest on this protein you
want to marry the force on this protein
so you you would insert the false sensor
or tension sensor into the middle of the
protein
but because the frag sensor the Fret is
the fluorescent readout you will also
need to control for the fluorescence Not
Just Between the donors and the
acceptors but the donor itself
accepts herself donor without acceptor
and acceptor without donor
such as here and here and there will be
no Force controls where you insert the
flat sensors each in into either the C
terminals or the n-terminants of the um
protein so those are the controls to get
the reliable fluorescent readout to
control for the function of the protein
to make sure that the insertion itself
does not lead to a dysfunction of the
protein you need to make sure that
the protein with the insert with the
fluores sensor inserted can rescue The
Knockout of cells where the original
protein is is gone
so this is the control to
to show that it's it's still functional
protein even with the insertion of the
big threat sensor the expression levels
need to be controlled and also the
Dynamics of the proteins also need to be
controlled
you can see you can see the control for
the fluorescent Lifetime and also and
then that's the majority of the controls
but to be able to use the flash sensor
you need to calibrate the fluorescent at
the beginning so this in kind of B you
can see how people use either magnetic
tweezers or Optical tweezers to
calibrate
the stiffness of the elastic Linker in
the middle and he finally that's the
thread measurement
usually you would have a a a decrease in
the flat efficiency with higher Force
but not shown here is the absolute uh
what the app the y-axis is not
um
labeled but the actual threat efficiency
is purely low and the difference in
threat efficiency is usually uh within
10 and the noisy level and noise levels
is also usually high and that's a noisy
measurement
um usually you have to control it very
carefully and you need to make sure you
do everything correct you have all the
actual uh all the card controls to make
sure the force measurement is correct
so those are the
difficulties of using the first sensor
is a great sensor it works in many many
situations but because of the number of
controls and because of the readout
which is based on threat you need to
um you need to uh it usually takes a
long time for you to get a real
experiment on any protein that you want
to know the force
and uh I can go to the next slide and
that's why we think there are room for
new sensor which ideally would be
smaller smaller meaning that if you
don't require threat without you don't
require two fluorescent proteins than
the size of the fresh sensor then the
size of the force sensor could be cut in
half at least
and ideally
you can consider uh the you can consider
making a four sensor that is based on
digital readout
as opposed to the
um analogous
no sorry pause
so a new file sensor can be
using a digital readout where the force
gives you a either yes or no answer
instead of a continuous readout because
a lot of the controls you generate when
using the front sensors is so you can
you can have a standard curve to know
where the force magnitude is
so that's what we want to do with the
new file sensor and actually a false
sensor based on DNA also already existed
that is smaller and based on digital
readout so this is one example the DNA
thread sensor uh yes DNA frag sensor but
it's between a fluorophore and a
quencher so the way the DNA file sensor
works is the DNA also has
a raptor Force threshold you can see
here in panel B
when the force is not applied on this
DNA hairpin the fluoride form country
are very close to each other then the
floor fluorescence is very uh
diminished because of the puncture
existed close to the 404 but it will
apply force on this DNA hairpin
then the Quinter will be further away
from the floor four you would have an
increase in fluorescence so this is what
what we call digital readout it's an on
or off response
depending on the presence or the absence
of force and you can tune the Rapture
threshold by changing the GC or at
content
percentage in The Hairpin you can see in
C by going from 22 percent DC to 100 cc
the Rapture force can go from 4.2 to 16
piconewton
so this is a digital readout based for
sensor which still relies on thread but
is outside the cells and it's a digital
readout so we want to develop a four
sensor that's similar in principle
and also gives you a yes or no answer so
that's why we are trying to use a new
protein well a protein Motif called
coils
as our element to build it to build the
new file sensor so a cold coil is made
of two arbalances you can see in panel a
it's a diagram to show how the car coils
are organized usually you have the uh
hydrophobic residues in the middle of
the Cod coil and the polar residue is on
the upside so the outside is more
hydrophilic hydrophilic and the middle
is more hydrophobic
if there's no Force then this would
exist in this confirmation as you can
see in b
it's a folded state
but from our collaborators and from the
literature we have found that if you
apply Force to this God coil structure
you can actually rupture it just like
you ruptured it in your hairpiece so I'm
going to show you uh on the next slide
this slide this is a
diagram for the card wire being pulled
by Optical tweezer from our collaborator
also at your from uni John lab
you can see the code coil is relatively
small it's four by two nanometers in
size
and if you use Optical tweezers to apply
Force to the two ends of the card coils
you can calibrate it in this particular
case
this card go out with arm fold at 11 pic
on your time
you can see the histogram at on panel C
it's 11 people Newton Raptor Force
meaning that if you apply a force
smaller than 11 Pico Newton on this
chord coil the cold coil would stay in a
voltage state but if you increase the
force to higher than 11 then it would
rupture unfold so we can consider one
called coil to be existing at two states
either folded or unfolded and the
unfolding of the Court coil would be
don't only happen if the force is higher
than its unfolding threshold
a nice thing about quad core is is
simple enough and we can tune the
Rapture Force while unfolding Force
threshold by changing early the heart of
obesity of the residues in the center of
the part file so here actually we have
already generated a library of gold
coils and we have calibrated them and
and and have known there are voting for
threshold all the red dots correspond to
different chord files you can see VR 14
first vessels
uh range from 3 to 20 typical Newton we
are making more based on different
templates of code files but this library
is growing
so the idea of generating this library
is that for each Cod coil if we insert
that code into a protein of Interest
you'll be asking a question
if the force on that card called bigger
or smaller than the unfolding Force
threshold of the Quad coil because if
the force is bigger than the threshold
then the code coil will be unfolded and
open if the force is smaller then the
curveball would be staying in a Fourier
state
by looking at the forest data because
you would know the force
and then the question is how do we know
if the code call is open or not in
available
I'm going to give you two examples to
show how we can use God gloves as for
sensors to measure the magnitude of
force in in those services on two
different proteins and with two
different readouts so in the first
readout I'm going to show you that the
insertion called Coil Plus some other
domains on that protein will lead to
protein condensation
and that is your readout in the second
example I'm going to show you that by
engineering by engineering the Linker of
the code call we can introduce different
readouts and not be limited in the use
of cfp as your readout
okay so this is the first example
uh these two proteins one is called n21
and the other is called N4
both have lipid binding domains and
actin binding domains the adapter
proteins in the process called
endocytosis where actin produces Force
to bend the membrane so the membrane
eventually deforms and reshape is being
reshaped into vesicle and being
transported into the cells uh in the
upper in sorry in the lower left you can
see uh
time lapse and those Services all the
black spots
uh and four proteins assembling and then
disassembling at endocytic sites
so on the lower right you can see a
common graph of this endocytic process
you can see again in the N4 proteins
first assemble and and then disassemble
so the force on and four proteins we
think would also first increase then
decrease if you insert the code coils
into this N4 protein
and if the force on that N4 protein
that increases to the level higher than
the unfolding Force threshold then the
core coil would be open and if the force
decreases then the cargo will be uh
would refold into the folded state
if you only have one call for us this is
a reversible process and nothing special
would happen
but if you have multiple uh insertion of
the code calls into different and for
proteins because the multiple copies of
un4 proteins very close to each other
what could happen is
once the code call is unfolded in the
refolding process if if the force drops
the refolding can happen between
different operations of the chord coils
so you can see on the right of this
slide three uh four different chord bars
we're floating onto each other to form
part walls so that's why the refolding
process will lead to the generation of
bigger intermolecular structures and
eventually lead to condensation of the
protein so the conversation would look
like that looks like this in penalty you
know why type which is panel F you can
see the normal endocytic patches where
N4 proteins assemble and onto window six
sites but if we insert the code calls
into N4 protein closer to the acting
binding site you start to see the
generation of bigger currencies which
are fluid like they actually facial
printed from the time lapse you can see
different droplets views and they also
under efficient they also undergo Theory
and fusion so this is a dynamic process
but the major point is the presence of
these condensates shows you that the
quad core has been opened by force which
means that the force unwind for protein
closer to its acting binding domain has
been up has been a higher than 11 people
and this is how you know
um the magnitude of the force using card
coils
so we did a further measurement of force
out and four we either we have we have
so we used uh four different chord coils
each having different uh false
thresholds it's 8 10 11 and 20. we
either inserted the same color into
different positions of the same M4
protein or we inserted uh different code
calls into different positions sorry
different positions of the same protein
and if you see the presence of the
condensates it means that the force is
higher than the force than the 14th
threshold so in this case
for the 8-Bit Newton cardboard which is
at the bottom of the uh left which has
which is at bottom left of this image
you can see the presence of communities
meaning that at all three positions when
four force is higher than eight
but the 10 Pico Newton cortical only
gives commences at the second and the
third position to burn four but not at
the first which means that force in the
first position of N4 protein is between
8 and 10. and this is how we discard
discovered using the code coil for
sensors a gradient of force along this
N4 protein it's tend to uh sorry it's 8
to 10. between is lipid binding and the
protein enrichment between 10 and 8 in
the middle protein and between 11 and 20
closer to its acting bonding domain so
this is one example showing you that the
force measurement on a protein inside
the cells uh independent threat
there could be other results which I'm
going to show you using the split trp
approach the split CRP works
because trp can self-reassemble if you
Pro provide both the 11th Strand and the
one to ten strand
and if you express the trp1 to 10 in the
cells and you'll see a P11 as the Linker
of a card coil then if the quad core is
in a voltage State the grp11 would not
be available for the reassembly of cfp
you would have no fluorescence but
fluorescence well be be there if the
trp11 has been exposed which will only
happen if the code coil has been opened
by force
so this is how by using 1tfp cut in half
you can reassemble
the fluorescence at the presence Force
if the force is higher than the
unfolding threshold of the cord coil I'm
I'm going to demonstrate how this works
on the other protein content one
here yeah so we constitutively
constitutively expressed GMP 1 to 10
infection is sales
and if we insert your P11 by itself into
this and one protein
also closer to its acting binding domain
we see fluorescent signals appearing at
the endocytic patches
if we bury the gf11 as a Linker into the
code coil and insert this for sensor
into the same position close to its
acting binding domain we see weaker
fluorescence because Erp 11 is only
transiently available if the force on
that protein is higher than three people
Newton
but what happens if we use the similar
same approach but replace the code file
to either 10 people Newton or 7
piconewton is there's no fluorescence so
this is a measurement showing us that
the force the magnitude of the force on
this n21 protein at this location is
between three and seven we also did
other controls to show how we can remove
we can we can either decrease the force
or increase the force by removing or um
changing rotating other domains Antoine
protein or other proteins uh but the
general principle is by using this
specific PRP approach we can have
another readout for our flaw sensor so
that's actually uh the end of my data uh
the summary is called Clause is a force
responsive element it's simple and
smaller than the frag sensors it's also
compatible with fresh sensors but we
would like to you sorry we would like to
uh keep using the code coils as a
building block
so that we can add different readouts
onto the sensor onto the linkers and by
using this we anticipate to be able to
measure forces on more proteins and have
more relapse and that's the end of the
talk I would like to acknowledge the
founding resources which is each and
also acknowledge the lab mates in my lab
in paralab
um um I also would like to help I also
would like to acknowledge the uh
collaborators in the John lab especially
uh who calibrated many of the card coils
and uh thank you all for your uh
attention thank you